[Musik]
gomez war jos singt vom frieden doch
sein leben prägte der krieg
[Musik]
in der zeit als ich die entscheidung
traf mich der guerilla anzuschließen
dachte ich dies sei eine alternative die
möglichkeit etwas zu verändern
ich sah wie sozialen verhältnisse
unseres volkes und vor allem meiner
familie
die arme bescheidene leute sind
sie lebten mit vielen unbefriedigten
grundbedürfnis
20 jahre lang war er ein kämpfer der
farc rebellen in kolumbien
seit den 1960 er hatte die
linksgerichtete guerilla einen
bewaffneten kampf gegen den staat
geführt der hauptauslöser extreme
soziale ungleichheit im land es folgte
ein jahrzehntelanger bewaffneter
konflikt mit gräueltaten von beiden
seiten mit mehr als
260.000 toten doch vor fünf jahren
einigten sich regierung und verkauf ein
friedensabkommen aufgaben er wollte raus
aus der gewaltspirale
die tatsache in ständiger unruhe und
sorge zu leben und jeden tag zu denken
der heutige könnte sein letzter sein das
erzeugt angst und schrecken
das wünscht man niemandem und deswegen
wollen wir heute kompletten frieden
erreichen
die unterzeichnung des friedensvertrages
im november 2016 ein meilenstein unter
un aufsicht gaben in den folgemonaten
rund 8000 ehemalige kämpfer ihre waffen
ab auch goma ob und wofür sie genutzt
hat erfahren wir nicht
heute würde am liebsten von seiner musik
leben doch das ist schwierig
wenn unsere lebensgeschichte bekannt
wird kommen oft vorbehalte auf
zum beispiel habe ich kameradinnen und
kameraden denen eine arbeitsstelle
verweigert wurde aufgrund der tatsache
dass sie unterzeichnende des
friedensabkommens also ehemalige kämpfer
sind und das passiert in vielen
bereichen ja wir nehmen stigmatisierung
war
stigmatisierung und ausgrenzung sind
nicht das einzige problem für die
ehemaligen kämpfer innen
der un sicherheitsrat hat heute die
kolumbianische regierung aufgefordert
die umsetzung des friedensabkommens
voranzubringen und mehr zu tun um die
ermordung entwaffnet kämpfer zu
verhindern
mehr als 200 95 ehemalige fahrer kämpfen
der boden laut un seit unterzeichnung
des abkommens getötet im schnitt eine
person alle sechs tage
wo einst die farc das sagen hatte
herrschen nun andere gewalttätige
kriminelle gruppen erklärt der direktor
des deutsch kolumbianischen friedens
instituts capas
viele bedrohungen gegen die ehemaligen
fahrt kämpferinnen und kämpfer diese
kommen einerseits von den dissidenten
der farc diejenigen die nicht im
friedensprozess sind sie kommen aber
auch etwa von von paramilitärischen oder
neo paramilitärischen gruppen und
teilweise eben auch von menschen die mit
dem die dann auch mit dem drogenhandel
verbunden sind
auch wegen dieser bedrohungen verdient
goma sein geld inzwischen hauptberuflich
als personenschützer vor allem arbeitet
er für politiker innen der partei
kommune die sich aus ehemaligen fahrt
mitgliedern gegründet hat und die nun
den politischen kampf sucht
frieden findet er in seinen liedern
[Musik]
seit der 6 ist singt und spielt gar die
traditionellen melodien und seiner
heimatregion genres orientalis
selbst in seiner zeit bei der fahrt
bleibt das so in der militärischen
tagesordnung der guerilla war am abend
meist zeit für kultur eingeplant
ich hatte immer die lautet dabei das hat
nicht nur mir sondern auch meinen
kameraden und kameradinnen mich manchmal
warten etwas zu singen immer dann wenn
es möglich war natürlich gab es
situationen in denen wir überhaupt keine
geräusche machen und schon gar nicht
singen oder ein instrument spielen
gefechte und gewalt gehörten zum alltag
gemeinte nur im bewaffneten kampf der
guerilla die extrem ungleichen
gesellschaftlichen verhältnisse
verändern zu können
sowie viele in kolumbien stammt komme
aus einer kleinen bäuerlichen familie
gesundheitsversorgung und höhere
schulbildung undenkbar für sie nach
gewaltsamer vertreibung verlor die
familie irland lebte lange in einer
winzigen baracke strukturelle probleme
die auch heute noch existieren
die landverteilung ist in kolumbien seit
jeher extrem ungleich 75% des produkte
produktiven landwirtschaftlichen fläche
sind im besitz von weit weniger als ein
prozent dies ist nicht nachhaltig und
dies führt immer wieder soziale
konflikte hier muss angesetzt werden wir
brauchen eine gerechtere verteilung des
landbesitzes in kolumbien auf dem weg
zum frieden hat kolumbien schon einiges
erreicht sagt stefan peters und lobt das
system der übergangsfristen doch
aufgrund des drogenhandels und der
gewalt bewaffneter gruppen in
verschiedenen regionen bleiben die
herausforderungen in der friedensprozess
nicht gescheitert gleichwohl ist in
einer schwierigen phase wir haben
aktuell eine situation dass abgewandelt
büchners formel wir vielleicht davon
sprechen könnten sie haben viele für die
paläste und krieg für viele hütten
gerade in den abgelegenen region hier
gilt es anzusetzen
hier braucht es die implementierung des
friedensvertrages aber auch eine politik
die sich die reduzierung der sozialen
ungleichheiten auf die fahnen schreibt
das will auch komme die hoffnung auf
eine gerechtere gesellschaft hat er nach
wie vor heute will er sie mit
politischen mitteln vorantreiben wie
viele ehemalige kämpfer innen hat er
inzwischen sogar eine familie sein sohn
ist drei monate familienleben war in
seiner zeit als kämpfer unvorstellbar
[Musik]
mitten in der militärischen
konfrontation watt es überhaupt keine
option
aber inzwischen in der neuen situation
hat sich alles anders ergeben und so ist
das eines der schönsten geschenke die
der frieden gebracht hat dieser
komplizierte frieden der trotz allem
eben auch geschenke des himmels bereitet
[Musik]
euro